a very interesting game for sure we
would say
for
wesley wesley in this tournament we've
we saw you win i i think about six weeks
ago
cup i remember now i was 27 when i first
when i last won again a year ago that's
true that's true yeah technically
correct yeah so first of all i'd like to
thank lord god jesus for letting me win
it's super hard to win even one game
there are definitely was interesting and
this game was sharp this game yeah got
got wild and busy pretty quickly yeah
before we analyze i wanna say shout out
to my young opponent john burke he's
only 20. he's got a lot of promise he's
a very aggressive player and last night
i checked his openings i was looking for
a way to try to play for a win with the
black pieces
but he knows his theory very well and i
considered playing other openings like
the sicilian or the car con but most
likely i'd get a worse position out the
opening so i didn't feel like playing it
and then i thought about the relopez but
it's also hard to play for a winter but
big shout out to him for not just
forcing the door with the white pieces
let me ask you this question uh because
we were debating this during the
broadcast yeah were you thinking from
move one i'm trying to beat this young
man after all he's he's not that
experienced at the u.s championship he's
a good player but you already by a
couple of hundred rating points or were
you just thinking solid play yeah first
of all uh
i wasn't
thinking up there so first of all i
think for a top player it's
almost impossible to gain rating in the
us championship there's just a lot of
talented lower rated players i think
their rating should be higher but
they're
like i think sam sebian for example or
robson's rating should be higher but or
lenderman they're because they're very
good players so
when you have the black pieces it's
difficult to play for win and this is my
70 us championship i've lost to some
2500s in the past i've lost to sam
sebian conrad holt a wonder amongst
others man you just remembered him off
the top of your head like that you yeah
you don't forget when you lose someone
200 points lower so
so also i think sam sebian he was 25 31
in 2015 and he beat me and he drew
against hikaru nakamura who was 27 98.
so i i think sometimes you just gotta
play your best and if it's a draw you
can move on i mean
john burke could go for this 14 move
repetition as as you can see this berlin
draw but he didn't big shout i think and
then update if you're if you're that
young i mean sure you can make a draw
get towards your rating points
but i think the experience is more
valuable absolutely yeah and also yeah i
couldn't just think of any opening to to
play for a win against one e4 mega try
the nightdorf but he knows it very well
indeed all right let's get into the game
because he got sharp and then yeah you
got a piece on d3 and he played b4 that
moment is a moment that was very
exciting
you could have grabbed the exchange
right away yeah but then you went for
the sharper more dynamic line take us
through your thinking process yeah first
of all the opening is nice because he
played this against bruzon so i was
hoping he would repeat it and prepared
this small surprise opening rookie eight
i think he became too greedy and took
this pawn i think accordion was saying
instead of c5 rook g6 is also very
strong
like here rook g6 i thought about rook
g6
and then i was analyzing rook e1
five
the knight f1
and he brings the knight to g3 but
apparently the computer says it's just
minus two like completely winning for
black after bishop g4 or something wow
i just didn't realize that this just
crashing
so if i if i saw bishop g4 with
an attack i would got gun for this
but uh yes i i think first of all his
pawn grabbing is just a big mistake
because he got worse position of the
opening
and i thought queen d1 was better i
couldn't see a refutation instead of
queen f4
but
yeah i couldn't guess his moves i
thought queen d1 i couldn't
black should be better but i couldn't
find a way to increase my advantage i'm
sure there is something
but yeah queen f4 bishop d3 i guess b4
is actually the only move because if
player e1 apparently there's some bishop
move like bishop g6 with the knight
coming to d3 yeah i don't know thinking
i wasn't sure where to put the bishop
but
yeah b4 was a very good practical try
and i wasn't expecting that but
yeah
yeah b b4 after b4 i mean black is
better but it's not not so easy
so
to
position apparently was very very sharp
and right very sharp
right here he had the move
queen queen f5 the engine actually
wanted to take on f1 originally but
queen f5 did you have something planned
against this uh
well yeah i i thought
yeah i was expecting d1 queen f5
g6 grenade bishop d4
and now just bishop f4 giving you
yeah i thought they found that dark
square giving you the rook but just the
dark square one yeah bishop a1 or k1
then i wasn't sure i mean black's got to
be better but he's got compensation if
he can get queen g3 and h4 in
um but at the same time
[Music]
yeah queen if win before roxy won
and uh
yeah you're right he shot gun for this
maybe this is his best defense yeah we
thought it was his best chance
when he missed this however then it
seemed that you had this great move e3
did you see this from afar away yeah
yeah i thought but i was like expecting
he would believe
maybe he missed it
we were expecting you to play f7 f6
right
i thought this move i just didn't
believe it could ever work
yeah we thought so ef if i was thinking
ef bishop e3 queen e3 e3 f7 king f8 the
black wings really wow yeah i thought f6
i just never thought it could ever work
you know
but maybe it does
i know no no you can't take there but 96
is also not possible so everything's
covered oh so f6 knight f3
it's pretty similar to what you had just
better better oh okay i didn't realize
why a bishop f100 f1 queen d3
and then he doesn't get the rook
in the game he had one last chance
uh the way you've played it it was right
about here
that he missed his
he missed his chance with knight h4 was
oh no
i was looking at like some d5 turkey
line d5 brook d5
rook c1 queen bit three okay just a
second let me catch up with you uh
tricky line yeah
yeah because he got back ranked queen d3
and now the important if if i if he
plays knight e1 he i have queen b5
protecting e8
oh that's a nice way meanwhile also it's
funny if we play e6 here yeah rook e6
knight e5
whoa
wait a minute wait a minute only one
winning move what what really is maybe
christian can find this now christian uh
rookie five twenty five twenty five yeah
you can't do that
yeah so here's the six maybe no way
seven
is hanging f7 is hanging
c8 is hanging okay wesley's giving us a
nice little test here because yeah you
all are grandmaster yeah right
you got it ah i got it so i was
calculating this but i didn't see knight
h4
yeah that was i we think it was his last
chance if rook makes before uh queen g5
win g5
oh and then you just go for a mating
attack yeah yeah the construction is
quite challenging for you oh also if i
play in flip queen rook before if i play
g6
jesus and win somewhere yeah queen jeff
g fight man you may have this move
oh yeah oh no that's check sorry let's
check on
that check on d4 sorry i think queen g5
oh now maybe knight back to f3
h6 that makes sense yeah and uh we've
got
yeah yeah this makes sense yeah we can
write dark squares also you can play h4
and i i did we both missed an h4 we
think that was the last
uh chance and when he went for what he
did in the game g4 looked so uh
you've got you've got everything covered
and you went on to
win rather comfortably
yeah yeah i think night age for your
right was his last chance to defend how
do you feel about the tournament right
now i mean you told us you were very
tired after a series of tournaments all
in a row
but you've landed squarely on your feet
wesley yeah again this today was a big
win i mean as i said even to win just
one game here is it's very tough also
all the top players losing rating
and uh yeah i was a year younger when i
last won a game
well let's start with it
[Laughter]
again
four rounds to go hey i think uh
congratulations on time for first yeah i
think i think we were discussing
yesterday
i think plus three will be good enough
for tide first
that shows how tough the field is only
four games left
so
it's going to be nice i'm gonna have
white more hopefully i can make
something out of my whites because
you're so good your memory is so
wonderful about the games and stuff like
that
we on panel here we had a lot of trouble
remembering when was the last time fabi
castled
that is to say losing two games in a row
oh castled losing two games in a row
yeah when did you lose two games in a
row
do you think two games in a row yeah
he
first of all he loses so rarely to begin
with but two games in a row okay he
loses blitz games yeah but blitz you got
to go to the velocity yeah classical
game yeah you're right probably
probably five years ago do you remember
a specific incident in your mind like
could he i knew he had a bad nah by
god's say one year oh yeah that's right
yeah yeah i have to go all the way all
the way all the way back 2018 so three
and a half years ago three and a half
years ago what is your opinion before
you go what's your opinion of this is
just winning for lanier
no no i thought the engine before coming
50 completely equal what this position
yeah
yeah it says that black should draw
without
i mean
black should draw with good with good
defense wow
yeah because c5 before
yeah
i think a more interesting end game is
actually the one between fabi and uh
yeah your opinion of uh this one
yeah why it has some
slight chances white's definitely
pushing bishop 1 g5 is very vulnerable
the questions whether
white can win or not but looks like
unpleasant defending for for black
bishop bishop f6 so 96 bishop f6 and
then black can only fit
so it's going to be long hard
defensively wesley we do have a segment
predict a result
so we're going to do it on this game
right now and we're going to include you
oh
oh
put him on the spot oh
i'm going to go with a victory for
fabiano i'm going to wait for wesley
no no no
way not allowed no no no
go ahead wesley no no wesley no we
cannot have wesley influence okay wesley
the last one
has to be the last one he's the
strongest player in the room
let him have the last pick all right all
right if i'm gonna go next
i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say draw
i'm gonna say draw
i'm gonna say white wins
thank you
[Music]
but this is a game where there's two
bishops versus bishop knight combination
we saw the longest game of the two yeah
i'm having bad memories about that game
alex slenderman uh but he was up apart
he was i'm a pawn in that one though but
you gotta lose upon soon or maybe maybe
one day that we thought that
you got some more to think about in this
round not just your win but whether or
not you might lose this predict your
first predictive result maybe i can
change
i missed no
i missed after bishop f6 black ass
bishop e8 software bishop f6 bishop e8
is important oh you already
[Laughter]
wins by fourth but it's going to be very
very hard defending very long game yeah
very helpful yeah congrats wesley thanks
for joining us and entertaining us as
well yeah
good luck in the rest of your games
tomorrow again thanks congratulations
wesley indeed good luck in the remainder
okay
what a